fresh off of covering last night's
Lakers and Thunder game downtown at the
downtown hoops dojo is none other than
NBA reporter from ESP and Dave McMenamin
good to see you sir
great to see okay very entertaining game
by the way you know what the Lakers are
an entertaining team yeah I mean I said
cuz we're talking about the home team as
well they're they're fascinating they're
fascinating with LeBron obviously and
then with him being out just to see who
can step up and maybe take the Lakers
off the max contract free agent hook
coming up next summer right wouldn't
feel so dire if they strike out on the
biggest names is Leo because we have
homegrown talent that's stepping up
right
the tough part like in the vacuum last
night you have calculus we're going out
with the back strain and he has really
been the most talented offensive player
of that young group and last year too
right I mean so it's now two years
running he's the guy yeah and then then
you see plays like Lonzo earlier on the
game - straight drives right into the
paint and eyes in the back of his head
fine guys four dunks who are trailing
like the elite level stuff but then he
goes and can't make a free throw he's
only getting one free throw attempt per
game which that means all that
penetration is going for not because
he's not either finishing at the rim or
trying to get contact perhaps he doesn't
want to go to the line so he's passing
on purpose he's gonna go to line and
miss hmm and then you have Ingram who
goes in and out of things and you know
it's a 5-point game in the fourth
quarter he's kind of playing that point
forward roll and he stripped at the top
of the key like cardinal sin and they
get a you know a breakaway bucket on the
other end right can't do that you got to
be able to check the ball if you're
gonna be the point for it on your team
and the Laker fans taunting we don't
whole George we don't need you excuse me
I mean are you kidding me we don't need
while that's happening you have this
scene playing out in the tunnel with
magic Rob palinka and LeBron all looking
like they just saw a family member get
shot based on one just found that
fascinating you know that that shot that
you're referring to and we're showing it
on the television
feed right now radio audience it's Rob
polenka on the Left Magic Johnson on the
right and LeBron who had been sitting on
the bench as an injured player dressed
in civilian clothes would do is standing
in between them and I'm wondering this
and I'm asking the gentleman to whom
LeBron said his thoughts like the
unsolicited Lee I imagine but I'll ask
that in a second about Anthony Davis how
amazing it would be to play and that
created a whole set - in the NBA about
whether that's technically tampering or
not even though he's not in the front
office isn't that exhibit a him standing
in between the two decisions - decision
makers for the Lakers as he was doing
that when that that that he is in fact
part of the decision-making process
there in Lawson yeah but okay it's a lot
different though being part of the
decision-making process and then being
the only way it could be considered
tampering is if they gave him a set of
instructions basically and he was
carrying out there their will by you
know talking about a player purposely to
the press mm-hmm LeBron operates under
his own free will and he doesn't need
magic or Rob to tell him these things to
carry them out so there we go it's not
tampering okay
so that said the visual as you pointed
out and before I even had it in the
chute to bring up because I wanted to
have it in the chute to bring up with
you sitting here walk me through when
LeBron came to you and gave you it did
he come to you I mean what was this
spatial actual we were in Brooklyn nuts
and bolts here we are in Brooklyn I had
just gone on SportsCenter to talk about
a podcast or parents or television
parents accuse me by Adrienne water now
ski where he talked about the Lakers
plans in terms of you know they had
already struck out on Trevor Ariza and
he's saying they're not going to pursue
smaller type deals in order to get
incrementally better they're gonna hold
on to all their young assets in order to
pursue anti Davis in a trade and so
SportsCenter was playing in the visitors
locker room at you know Barclays Center
LeBron is getting stretched out watching
the TV on mute
sees me there sees the b-roll of Anthony
Davis I come into the locker room and he
says something along the lines of do you
know something I don't know which
prompted our conversation about they
Davis we go back and forth and then you
know gave I asked him so you know what
do you think about them trading for him
and he gave me that quote and and of
course you had to have an exchange after
that you know we've all that kind of had
these type of conversations before being
a reporter is it on the record is off
the record
now he said it was on the record so of
course there's where he's giving the
tacit agreement where he knows what he's
doing he knows that there'll be a ripple
effect when he says it on the record so
ok he did not specifically seek you out
out of the blue it was something where
you strolled in and he just saw
something very said that the timing of
it like had I not come into the locker
room after the TV David doesn't so so
and you being the professional lead-pipe
wielding professional that you are Dave
McMenamin of ESPN you went to him and
say hey I want to make sure that that
what you just told me was on the record
and he said yeah it is correct and
that's when he knows as a shop and the
guy who's every social media movement
that's been calculated in a way gave
that that remark ok so what do you think
the possibility is is we're currently
sitting here on the first Thursday of
January how many days we 36 days away
from the done line ok what do you think
so
the Lakers have this young core of
assets we know that right there's other
teams that have great things they could
offer as well specifically the Boston
Celtics the Boston Celtics cannot make
an offer for an Anthony Davis until the
offseason unless they include Kyrie
Irving in that offer which is not having
right of course not that that's your
championship point guard list so this is
the moment where the Lakers can strike
without Danny Ainge having a
single-syllable of saying to what could
be done yes so with Anthony Davis
instead of sending him to the window is
open right now and you could say he's
under contract right but guess what
Jimmy Butler was under contract Kyrie
Irving was under contract while Leonard
was under contract the NBA in this
current landscape
if the superstar puts it out there that
he wants to be out the team is
handcuffed they have to do it and it
becomes a diminishing asset the longer
you wait and the Lakers if Nancy Davis
makes it clear he wants to be traded
once to be traded to the Lakers there
could be a bold team out there that says
you know what we'll trade for him anyway
and we'll convince him with our cultured
like Paul George a clerk at work OKC the
Thunder but that's that's a risk in Sam
Presti s type of clout and okay seed to
pull a move like that but not every GM
does and you know it could be a manifest
destiny if Anthony Davis now he has to
take the leap as a 25 year old who's
lived in relative obscurity in the NBA
even though he has all these accolades
he doesn't really get flack because
there's not a ton of media attention
down in New Orleans he will change his
public perception dramatically if he was
to go out and publicly request a trade
you got to live with that fallout well
he you can't do it collective bargaining
agreement says you can't come out and
literally say I want to trade correct
correct you can which is why you know
the whole Jimmy Butler situation kind of
skated on the thin ice of whether he had
broken the collective bargaining
agreement of coming out and saying it
although calling Rachel Nichols up and
say won't you fly out to Minnesota and
I'll have an outburst while you're in
flight that I know is gonna create such
a major problem that we'll chat on on
the jump you know as you pointed out as
well I mean the NBA is filled with savvy
stars who know when they say something
what it means to say it and how they can
put it out there has a lot to say with
whether they can be caught on the carpet
for it Dave McMenamin here on the Rich
Eisen show so Anthony Davis were the
only reason why we're making these
connection is because of clutch sports
representing both of these superstar
athletes and LeBron and Anthony Davis
and Anthony Davis has yet
to form a super team by going somewhere
okay so he's he hasn't done that yet and
if it's something he does want to do and
he's 25 and by age 30 LeBron may have
moved on after having played with his
son here in Los Angeles then he's got
his entire 30s to be a Laker Superstar
of his own right he does but at the same
time
I mean his entire NBA career has been a
disappointment terms of winning I mean
he's been an undisputed top seven or
eight player in the league for the last
four or five years and what does he have
to show for it a couple first-round
exits and so you now you have guys like
Kevin Garnett you know legends of the
game saying you know you should do what
I did you know I stayed too long in
Minnesota I should have made the Boston
move away earlier in my career telling
him these type of things too because you
only get one go-around in this league
and if he's gonna waste the start of his
prime losing and losing and losing and
that's what they're doing again this
year I mean hyper-competitive Western
Conference and they are under 500 and it
doesn't seem to be a path for them to
get over 500 so is he gonna miss the
playoffs this year and do it out of out
of you know well this is what's right
for the organization and just bide my
time and then I'll go to LA at some
point and hope things get better in New
Orleans I don't that doesn't seem
reasonable compared to the rest of the
Superstar peers well now you're being
Dave McMahon I'm an ESPN now you're
being factually astute which you know
doesn't really help the purposes of this
sort of fantasy basketball trade
conversations or so while we're in the
world of actual facts who would the
Lakers be able to call fault that that
that Dell Demps in New Orleans would go
okay I'll be totally roasted by sending
Anthony Davis with in conference to
LeBron James and create a super team for
a team that desperately needs that sort
of bailout if you will sure so who could
that possibly I mean it would have to be
Ingram Lonzo Kuzma if not Ingram Alonzo
Kuzma and Josh Hart like I mean they'd
had to empty the cupboard to get him and
then that creates a new problem for the
Lakers because then basically you're
stuck in the situation that Miami was in
that the Cleveland Cavaliers
was like then you're filling out the
rest of the roster with a bunch of one
year veteran minimum contracts and that
can be problematic but I think that'd be
a good problem for the I mean wouldn't
the Lakers do that no I think they would
because we saw what those four guys can
do together last year and I know we're
kind of seeing what they're doing
together right now but I mean that that
that's not I mean with all due respect
can they gel together and beat the
lawyers can they gel together beat the
Rockets can they shell together in one
and even beat the New Orleans pelicans
right I mean they did with LeBron they
beat the pelicans earlier this year it
was like a close game but yes second
about you know without LeBron it's what
I'm saying is that you know you they're
waiting they're waiting for one of these
guys to turn into another guy I keep
using this Brock when I keep using this
analogy
Oladipo like they need they're coming
out of nowhere lightning strike this is
the new star of the NBA who-who was
toiling away in in in youthful you know
anonymity in a way this is the biggest
question I think Ingram is the guy that
people still believe could do that
because he's so young and his body
hasn't filled out hardly at all yet
right and he has the length and the
court vision and the athleticism where
you're like he could put it together and
make that next leave but you would have
to get a team to buy into that to make a
trade like this now it's it's not an
easy proposition but we don't know
what's in the heart and mind of Dell
Demps know okay yes I want to hold on
Nancy Davis that's a smart move right
but if you have to move them then it's
like okay is this a good package or is
there some type of deal that's out there
because no one really knew about the
Terrano deal when you talk about Kauai
like no one has assumed that was coming
right and then all of a sudden a team
offers a multi-time all-star in his
prime to get him is there a similar deal
that's out there somewhere that we're
not thinking about that
even though Boston can't be a part of
this this prot trade process right now
right that this other team would come
out of nowhere and blow the Lakers offer
a little here's what I'm hoping I'm
hoping that that the Lakers call up Dell
Demps and say Ingram Kuzma Hart ball
four
or Anthony Davis just named somebody
else whoever it is
Alfred Payton ok very good he's got a
great head of hair
oh did he really damn it
and and then Adam silver says well it's
that traits not have Lakers would lock
by the commissioner and then he just
trashes Dell Demps ten years later in
the in the Athletic what else is going
on I mean I mean that's the best team in
the East is it the Celtics out there
Brockman I don't know man great
performance out of Gordon Hayward last
night after putting it was a hero right
the game or but it we just can't figure
out a consistent line up
who's we wide open three sometime this
Boston team cannot do oh my god so our
Celtics head to the next Super Bowl well
you know yeah come come this year come
down this year in Atlanta and we're
Celtics ed I just think the way Yanis is
playing right now and Kawhi Leonard the
Bucks and the Raptors are the two best
teams in the either yeah Kawhi is coming
back tonight he's not he's not saying
anything off so what what happened what
happened I'm on everyone there's got to
be some chatter here Dave the chatter is
that his kind of consulting family
members etc they didn't believe that he
could live as I guess superstar of a
life in San Antonio based on the way the
organization treated him based on the
way he got deals off the court and they
wanted you know there was reports about
how he goes to all-star and felt like he
wasn't getting the same type of like car
service that other superstars for
getting what yes come on Hal yeah
what do you mean like I mean literally
like you know like he he saw how other
superstars the the the organization
treated them in terms of taking care of
everything soup to nuts when they're at
all-star weekend and he was like well
why am I get my man I couldn't treat it
like that you know San Antonio has a
clear culture where it's
your ego at the door you know great
puppets always says that nobody's bigger
than the team well maybe he wanted to be
bigger than that scene so if he if he
and his his family got more souped-up
car service he'd still be a that was
just its small anecdote okay
I mean listen you he went to a place
that has been lusting for a star ever
since Vince Carter's burned them and as
great as Kyle Lowry and DeMar DeRozan
were as a tandem and they were great
they won the East several times they
didn't have that next level stardom and
Toronto's roll out the red carpet and
beyond that they're doing the guy quite
letters in the prime of his career and
sitting out back to backs and no one's
given him pressure to play and nobody's
saying I know I hate it's y los angeles
yes he sat out both Lakers and Clippers
names by the way and they whipped him
both to it I mean they passed osteotomy
whipped him there too and but where's
the fallout for that you know like he's
just operating in a little bubble up
there and they're winning a lot of games
and how's the cars how the car doesn't
matter he's gonna be on the Clippers
with Durant next year you think I think
the Clippers would love for that to
happen I don't know I I was probably
gonna go to the finals and so not that
he stepped away from a team that won a
championship my final it VP so he's
already done that so maybe maybe you
couldn't leave a team that made the
files but all-star games in Charlotte
this year right yeah can you rent a
Maybach there for a family I mean it
roll out the carpet there for that and
then Toronto maybe they feel like
they're the tweet the show later whoever
wrote that they might have been Ramona
Shelburne and Michael Ryder had that
kind of it but yeah and we over
overlooking more the Bucs in the Nuggets
probably the Nuggets but we've seen this
before George Karl was coach of the year
is the last year in Denver then he got
fired
they got fired they put together a ton
of wins yeah they get that altitude it's
a real thing
it's a real home court advantage they
have during the regular season do they
have top-level talent to beat other
top-level talent in the playoff series
maybe they do it I mean I guess I mean
Yogi's it's awesome but I feel like you
could allow him to have everything run
through him and shut off the rest of the
guys and you're probably gonna win the
game and then you know they're best wing
player I like him a lot to Maul Mary but
you picked Jamal Mary over Russell
Westbrook or Jamal over
Steph Curry or LeBron James if they meet
one of those teams in playoffs right now
Denver's a 1 seed Lakers are the eight
seed you're gonna pick the Denver
Nuggets to beat the Lakers if LeBron's
healthy no chance
like come on yeah and the Lakers are
about to be there what they're for over
there about to be five over because the
the Knicks who are doing a great job at
anchor coming in to come another Friday
night can't wait should I call sousou's
you know she's got the official podcast
we've talked about having me appeared on
I'm booking a show for cities right yeah
she's doing the official Lakers podcast
do we just get the sitter and go out
there and watch the Knicks tank for
thank you so against the LeBron 'less
Lakers come on let's do it
that's a good friend of a scion sign Oh
tank for Zion Deb
that'd be impressive oh man I mean
you'll get on SportsCenter last one for
you yes how long do you know I've known
him since my freshman year of college
oh my god she doesn't but then so he was
my boss I did intramural refereeing he
was in charge of the referee what's more
frightening Dell 2fo being a cop God be
the ref exact an official in charge of
officials not are you serious I'm
serious what was he like work Stein we
used to play rate but so he was we used
to play a lot ton of pickup and then you
know life takes you different directions
I was aware of Chris Brockman of NFL but
didn't realize it was my intramural ref
so fast forward 2014 summer we're at a
party in Santa Monica like Oh
we know each other and so we reconnected
so you were you we see like the dick
Bavetta of it I mean like what was he
showed up to intramural games to watch
you rather intimidating goatee back in
the day correct basketball games right
in case you're wondering this has all
been on the record day at McCain MC T en
on twitter has LeBron followed you again
be back in Polk at it so come on with I
guess you're not gonna be on the shop no
Dave McMenamin go enough follow him on
Twitter and check out everything that he
writes and talks about on the worldwide
leader in sports a Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience